hey Leute hier ist die montags
Motivation werde gerade ein bisschen
down habt ihr gerade keinen Bock zu
arbeiten bringt ja auch oh der Job ist
irgendwie so eintönig irgendwie sieht
auch gar niemand was ich so mache hier
hier kommt eure montags Motivation
immerhin seid ihr nicht Karl Lauterbach
den Karl Lauterbach hat heute eine
Pressekonferenz gegeben zu Corona ja
also super wichtig riesige rot müsste
ich impfen nur im Schlaf blablabla alle
über 60 bis 70 impfen okay ist richtig
aber boring oh mein Gott da konnte schon
selber keinen Bock auf die
Pressekonferenz die ganze Zeit heute
mehr Box drauf oh mein Gott ja jetzt so
schlimm ist doch gar nicht oder also
holt euch den Montag Champions